aujourd'hui c'est le grand retour des
vidéos hardcore donc on va parler des
mathématiques dédiées à démocratiques en
particulier de la médiane géométrique si
vous ne voyez pas du coup de quoi je
parle je vous renvoie vers la dernière
vidéo que j'ai faite qui s'appelle les
maths desire démocratiques ou je parle
notamment de cet objet qui est la
médiane géométrique donc aujourd'hui
donc vidéo hardcore on va rentrer un peu
dans les détails en particulier de la
preuve qu'on a
coécrite avec d'autres chercheurs sur la
stratégie professionnelle c'est à dire
les intérêts à mentir lorsqu'on utilise
la médiane géométrique et voilà j'espère
que vous êtes prêts et que vous êtes
bien accroché parce que ça va être un
épisode d'accord donc ça peut être
forcément facile à suivre
alors pour commencer je vais vous
rappeler ce qu'est la médiane
géométrique donc comme je l'ai dit dans
la vidéo en fait la façon la plus simple
de définir la médiane géométrique c'est
comme étant le minimum d'une d'un
problème d'optimisation en l'occurrence
on reçoit un certain nombre grand V de
vecteurs donc V c'est pour voter donc
c'est une version anglaise et les
électeurs et donc on suppose qu'on a un
nombre grand V d'électeurs qui
participent au système et chacun des
électeurs va fournir un vecteur supposé
qu'il s'agit d'un vecteur dans l'espace
client RD donc typiquement et donc dans
cet espace client c'est naturel de
définir la médiane géométrique comme
étant un point qui est mise à somme des
distances au vecteur de chacun des
électeurs donc là je m'énerve
géométrique minimise est un hargimine de
la somme des distances au têta V vous
pouvez varie de 1 jusqu'à grand V c'est
à dire que V est un des électeurs donc
pour utiliser le langage un peu plus du
machine learning on va appeler la somme
des distances comme étant la l'os donc
la fonction pas à minimiser la fonction
de perte parfois on l'appelle et cette
fonction de perte donc c'est une
fonction du point Z et donc le minimum
est atteint un million de géométrique et
ça c'est intéressant de voir comment
cette fonction de perte varie en
fonction de la valeur de Z mais
également en fonction de la valeur des
en particulier d'un têta V malveillant
ou stratégique plutôt donc c'est
vraiment ce qu'on va faire dans cette
vidéo et on va voir que beaucoup des
propriétés qu'on a démontré découlent de
cette étude de cette fonction en
particulier après chose qu'on peut voir
c'est que la condition d'optimalité qui
correspond à dire que le gradient de de
cette loss par rapport à Z est égal à 0
en la médiane géométrique ça ça se
traduit par lorsqu'on calcule les
dérivés en fait des des normes en fait
le gradient du norme c'est égal au
vecteur unitaire et ça vous pouvez le
démontrer
mathématiquement suivi de faire les
calculs mais je trouve ça plus
intéressant d'avoir l'intuition
géométrique derrière ça ben
intuitivement d'un point de géométrique
qu'est-ce qui se passe tout simplement
lorsque l'on se déplace le long du
vecteur d'un pas
la distance la norme du coup va
augmenter de ce nombre de pas donc la
distance augmente proportionnellement au
nombre de pas même est égal au nombre de
pas que l'on fait si ce pas est effectué
dans la direction qui va du point Z au
TTV et donc le fait qu'il est cette
relation ça me fasse mieux un vecteur
unitaire et pareil la direction nous dit
bien que que ce gradient est dans la
direction de tetavé - Z
notre façon de voir ça c'est que si on
se déplace perpendiculairement à la
direction que tu avais - Z à ce moment
là en première au premier ordre la
distance ne va pas évoluer puisque si on
se déplace orthogonalement à cette
direction bah on va se déplacer
ponctuellement sur le cercle de centre
téta V et qui par Z et du coup la
distance sera inchangée donc c'est pour
ça que le gradient de la norme est égal
un vecteur unitaire de direction que tu
avais - Z même plus précisément c'est
dans la direction Z moins étave et donc
la condition d'équilibre nous dit
simplement que la somme des vecteurs
unitaires qui vont de la médiane
géométrique vers les tétave la somme de
ces vecteurs doit-elle à 0 et ça revient
vraiment à dire que chacun tire avec une
force unitaire sur un million
géométrique et la somme des forces
s'annule quelques quelques autres
remarques que j'ai envie de faire sur la
médias géométrique avant de passer à
l'étude des incitatif qu'elle provoque
une propriétaire attrillante d'un
million de géométrique c'est que
puisqu'elle minimise une fonction qui
est invariante par isométrie c'est à
dire qu'il est temps juste de cette
norme quotidienne si on fait n'importe
quel opération isométrique sur l'espace
alors ça va déplacer à median
géométrique de cette même transformation
isométrique il y a une invariance par
isométrie d'une certaine manière en
particulier c'est-à-dire que si on
tourne l'espace par exemple et bien de
90 degrés ou de 45 degrés alors la
médiane géométrique va se déplacer
également de cette rotation de 45 degrés
pareil sur la translation donc il y a
pas mal d'invarences qui sont assez
satisfaisantes d'un point de vue
géométrique en tout cas de la médiane
géométrique ni une autre propriété que
j'ai mentionné dans la fin de la vidéo
précédente qui est particulièrement
intéressant de géométrique c'est que la
mienne géométrique appartient
nécessairement à l'enveloppe convexe de
l'ensemble des vecteurs qui lui sont
rapportés et ça pour le démontrer en
fait une preuve assez joli qui consiste
à dire que supposons par l'absurde que
cette minette géométrique elle n'est pas
dans cette enveloppe convexe alors il
existe forcément un hyper plan qui
sépare cette médiane géométrique des
autres points des têta V et à ce moment
là ça c'est clair que la somme des
forces vertes va pointer dans la
direction qui va de la méthode
géométrique vers cette hyper plan qui
sépare
z2tav en particulier cette somme des
forces ne peut pas être nulle et donc on
a une absurdité puisque somme des forces
amidon géométriques nécessairement égal
à zéro et donc ça ça montre que
forcément la médiane géométrique est
dans l'enveloppe convexe c'est quelque
chose d'assez satisfaisant en
particulier pour les applications comme
le vote byzien sécurisé dont peut-être
que je ferai une vidéo hardcore dédiée à
ça pour vous présenter le problème donc
corriger des personnes pour une voix
très vite dessus
mais en attendant que j'ai le temps et
la motivation de faire ça je peux dire
vraiment dans quelques mots rapidement
en fait ce qui m'intéresse dans le cas
du vote basicien sécurisé c'est de
généraliser les préférences de quelqu'un
à partir seulement de ceux qui l'a
exprimé et une façon de faire c'est de
voir comment les jugements qu'il a
effectués par exemple covary avec les
jugements effectués par des gens qui
sont semblables ou pas à lui et donc
derrière ce calcul de la généralisation
des scores d'une individu il y aura ce
calcul
naturellement qui apparaît d'une matrice
de covariance des préférences exprimées
par différents contributeurs et jusque
là à ma connaissance il y a très peu de
recherches sur l'estimation
d'une matrice de covariance de manière
robuste et en particulier je ne connais
pas de travaux qui cherchent à faire
cela en calculant explicitement
l'influence maximale d'un contributeur
sur cette matrice de covariance alors
sur tournesol on utilise beaucoup des
médianes par coordonnées mais dans le
cas des matrices de cohérence et une
mauvaise idée d'utiliser une médiane par
coordonnée puisque si on calcule par
exemple chaque coefficient de la matrice
de covariance en prenant par exemple des
médias par coordonnées et bien on a
aucune garantie que ceux qui sera obtenu
et bien une matrice de covariance en
particulier que ce soit une matrice
semi-définie positive et ça ça vient
vraiment du fait que la médiane par
coordonnée n'est pas dans l'enveloppe
convexe des vecteurs qui lui sont
rapportés on peut prendre un cas qui
illustre très bien un cas très simple
imaginons qu'on a trois vecteurs de
coordonnées en dimension 3 1 0 0 1 0 0 1
alors l'enveloppe convexe de ces trois
points c'est ce qu'on appelle le simplex
correspond en gros à l'ensemble des
probabilités sur trois éléments donc
c'est l'ensemble des tels que la somme
des coordonnées est égale à 1 et tel que
toutes les coordonnées sont
supérieures égales à 0 sauf que bien sûr
si on prend la médiane par coordonnée
comme sur chaque coordonnée en fait il y
a une majorité de points qui sont égaux
à zéro la médiane par coordonnée sera le
vecteur 00 qui n'est clairement pas dans
l'enveloppe convexe des vecteurs
rapportés et ça ça fait que c'est une
mauvaise idée d'utiliser des idées comme
la médiane par coordonnée pour faire des
estimations d'objets comme des matrices
de covariance qui doivent appartenir à
un sous-espace convexe qui va
typiquement être un espace qui contient
l'ensemble des vecteurs qui lui sont
apportés et donc l'idée derrière le vote
bayésien sécurisé c'est vraiment
d'utiliser des estimateurs de matrice de
covariance à base de médias une
géométriques et même ce que j'ai en tête
c'est d'être un peu plus robuste encore
que cela en ajoutant une régularisation
puisqu'on sait que notamment depuis
notre article sur la les algorithmes de
tournesol mais resta et en particulier
un objet qui s'appelle la médiane
quasiatiquement régularisé on sait que
rajouter cette collation
permet vraiment de contrôler l'impact
maximum d'un individu unique sur
l'estimateur et ça c'est très bien parce
que ça permet de limiter exactement
l'influence maximale d'un individu
typiquement sur les scores qui sont
calculés et c'est une étape du coup
nécessaire par exemple si on fait de la
généralisation c'est assez vicieux en
fait de contrôler l'effet de chacun
puisque chacun peut modifier la matrice
de covariance et cette médication de
matrice de cohérence peut modifier les
scores généralisés de beaucoup d'autres
personnes et du coup a priori on risque
de perdre beaucoup de robustesse en
utilisant ce type de généralisation mais
avec ces idées de médiane géométriques
régularisées quadratiquement je pense
qu'on peut éviter tout cela mais voilà
il faut faire l'étude pour être précis
et en particulier faire les analyses
vraiment de boutons bout pour mesurer à
chaque fois l'impact maximal d'un
individu et pouvoir le contrôler une
autre propriété remarquable de la
médiane géométrique c'est sa robustesse
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que même
si on a disons un tiers des
contributeurs qui sont en fait
extrêmement malveillants
et qui sont qui veulent pousser la
médiane géométrique aussi loin que
possible
en fait il y aura un pouvoir limité à ce
qui ce qu'ils feront et ça on peut le
voir à nouveau avec cette idée de force
unitaire essentiellement supposons que
la plupart des contributeurs se trouvent
par rapporte des vecteurs qui sont dans
une région donnée et bien si les
attaquants mettent des vecteurs très
très loin et bien ils pourront pas
déplacer trop loin la médiasiométrique
puisque d'un moment lorsqu'on se place
très loin et bah on voit que toutes les
forces unitaires des contributeurs
initiaux vont plus ou moins s'aligner et
tirer dans le même sens et comme ils
sont plus nombreux ils vont tirer plus
fort que la minorité d'utilisateurs
malveillants et du coup la médiane
géométrique pourra pas aller trop loin
en gros savoir les histoires d'angle si
vous voyez un peu l'intuition derrière à
quel point ça peut aller loin et tout ça
est démontré de façon plus formelle dans
notre article une dernière chose que
j'aimerais signé par pas me dire
géométrique c'est qu'on peut démontrer
ce qu'elle fait une erreur par rapport à
l'estimation de la moyenne mais une
erreur qui est forcément borné par
quelque chose qui correspond vraiment à
cet hétérogénéité parmi les vecteurs
bien sûr s'ils sont tous égaux à la même
chose la moyenne est égale à médiane
géométrique qui est égale à la valeur en
commun qu'ils prennent mais s'il y a
plus de variances entre les différents
vecteurs des électeurs à ce moment-là il
y a une erreur mais cette erreur est
bornée par mesure de cette variance
exactement qui est proportionnelle à
racine carrée de la trace de la matrice
de covariance entre les différents
vecteurs et d'ailleurs cette remarqué et
valide exactement telle qu'elle pour la
médiane par coordonnées aussi ça permet
de faire un lien avec un autre article
qu'on a écrit le fameux article que
Google a tenté de censurer qui était
reporter notamment dans l'université qui
lui explique que plus il y a
d'hétérogénéité parmi les contributeurs
honnêtes plus c'est facile de manipuler
en fait dans le cas de la médiane
géométrique on voit ça très bien puisque
intuitivement si les gens sont
éparpillés partout et ben il y a plus de
moyens d'action pour les attaquants même
s'il représente qu'un tiers des
participants ou
une fraction plus faible encore des
participants c'est pour cela que
l'hétérogénéité parmi les contributeurs
honnêtes et vraiment une source de
vulnérabilité pour la sécurisation d'un
algorithme de machine learning
typiquement
ok c'est prémunère étant terminé
maintenant j'aimerais parler un peu plus
de la sortie poufs et de l'idée de la
preuve et vraiment que ça soit la preuve
négative ou positive les deux dans les
deux cas en fait on va étudier ce qui se
passe de manière à synthétique et ça va
vraiment correspondre à étudier ce qui
se passe au niveau de la cette loss
fonctionne de cette fonction de perte
quand il y a un très grand nombre de
utilisateurs et pour bien étudier cette
façon cet aspect de la stratipowness une
première marque que l'on peut faire
c'est que on peut isoler le contributeur
stratégique donc là je vais lui en
donner un indice zéro donc ce Posca V
auteur honnête et qui rapporte certains
vecteurs voilà qui sont fixés en fait on
s'en fout qu'il soit honnête ou pas ce
qui compte c'est que leur vecteur se
fixer et ce qui va m'intéresser de me
poser la question pour le contributeur
stratégique du coup avec un indice zéro
ou est-ce qu'il peut placer son vecteur
pour rapprocher autant que possible la
médiane géométrique de son vrai un vrai
vecteur qui préfère
et donc plus généralement en fait la
question qu'on va se poser c'est quels
sont les lieux possibles de la médiane
géométrique lorsque ce contributeur 0 se
déplace et choisit là où enfin le
vecteur qu'il rapporte donc ça dans
l'article on parle de bows 7 donc c'est
à dire l'ensemble des lieux de la
médiane géométrique qui sont réalisables
par cette individu stratégique et bien
l'une des remarques importante pour la
preuve qui est assez naturelle qui est
assez simple c'est que l'ensemble de ces
lieux possibles correspond à l'ensemble
des endroits où le gradient de la los
fonction par rapport à ce point en
question si on regarde uniquement les
électeurs qui sont pas le lecteur
stratégique
l'ensemble des lieux où ce gradient et
de Nord inférieur ou égal à 1 bien c'est
exactement l'ensemble des points
atteignables en effet il suffit à ce
moment-là pour l'individu stratégique de
rapporter exactement ce point pour
garantir que le point en question sur un
point d'équilibre puisque d'une certaine
manière le gradient qu'il aura à ce
moment là contre commencera tous les
autres radians de
façon plus formelle faudrait parler de
sous gradient pour formaliser la preuve
et c'est ce qu'on fait dans l'article
mais voilà intuitivement si la somme des
forces des autres et inférieur à 1 je me
plains quelque part et de toute façon je
vais tirer avec ma force égale à 1 à ce
moment-là je contrôle balance toutes les
forces des autres et du coup c'est une
position d'équilibre et donc ce qui nous
intéresse vraiment c'est d'étudier
l'ensemble des points où la somme des
forces des autres est inférieure égale à
1 et là l'idée fondamentale c'est quand
on se déplace légèrement par rapport à
la médiane géométrique des utilisateurs
autre que le lecteur 0 à ce moment là le
gradient va varier il va prendre une
valeur qui va donner par la dérivée
seconde donc l'approximation de la
dérivée première autour d'un point on
obtient comme la dérive seconde fois en
gros le déplacement et donc ça reste
vrai en dimension supérieure et du coup
le gradient prêt du point d'équilibre
est donné par H fois la déviation que
l'on fait donc si je fais une déviation
X par rapport aime bien géométrique
alors le gardien que j'obtiens est en
première approximation égale à H fois X
en particulier la norme de ce gradient
et puis je vais même étudier la norme au
carré parce que c'est plus facile en
terme de calcul l'ensemble des points
qui sont atteignables en fait c'est
également l'ensemble des points tel que
la norme du gradient au carré est un
fabricant 1 alors l'ensemble des CP
points doivent vérifier que la norme du
coup de hache fois X ou H7 dérivée
seconde cette matrice sienne donc la
norme au carré de HX qui est égal à X
transpose hHX ça ça doit être inférieur
égal à 1 et donc en premier
approximation si vous connaissez un peu
ce genre d'équation vous savez que du
coup l'ensemble des points atteignables
ressemble à une ellipsoïde c'est-à-dire
un ensemble de points tels que en gros
une forme quadratique et inférieure égal
à un nombre et donc cet ensemble de
points accessible ça va être du coup une
ellipse qui sera très aplatie si
intuitivement du coup il y a beaucoup de
variations entre les valeurs propres de
cette matrice essienne c'est à dire que
selon certaines directions
la matrice ancienne prend une grande
valeur de direction la matrice essienne
prend de petites valeurs donc quand je
parle de polarisation en fait dans la
vidéo principale je parle vraiment de à
quel point cette matrice essienne et
aplatie sachant que les directions selon
lesquelles l'ellipsoïdes et aplaties
correspond en fait à des endroits où les
gens sont très polarisés puisque ça tire
vraiment des deux côtés et du coup c'est
difficile de déplacer cette très bien
des deux côtés et du coup c'est très
difficile de déplacer la médiane
géométrique vers le haut vers le bas
puisqu'il en gros il y a les forces sont
déjà là en présence et sont déjà bien
ancrées alors que sur la partie
orthogonale lorsque c'est bien aplati
correspond plus à des directions où les
gens sont un peu éparpillés et du coup
il y a moyen d'influencer beaucoup plus
en se positionnant à gauche ou à droite
ok donc tout ça ça me dit l'ensemble des
points Athéniens mais ça ne dit pas
vraiment les initiatives de
l'utilisateur 0 donc en particulier à
quel point il peut gagner en montant sur
là où il est on sait qu'il peut réaliser
n'importe quel point de l'ensemble dans
l'ellipseoïde et a priori il va vouloir
prendre le point du coup qui est le plus
proche de lui-même et on sait qu'il peut
l'atteindre tout simplement en
rapportant le point dans cette région de
l'ellipsoïde ok mais du coup la question
c'est est-ce qu'il y a un point dans
cette ellipsoïde qui est beaucoup plus
proche de lui que naît le point qu'il
obtiendrait s'il était honnête dans sa
manière de rapporter sa position donc
imaginons que sa position préférée est
ici donc j'ai appelé ça téta 0 avant de
parler de cette stratégie optimale si on
estimait déjà où se trouve la médiane
géométrique lorsqu'il le rapporte de
manière honnête ça son vrai vecteur à ce
moment là on sait que forcément le point
qui rapporte devrait être tel que le
gradient qu'il rapporte doit annuler le
gradient rapporté par les autres
vecteurs or le gradient rapporté par les
autres vecteurs on sait qu'il est égal à
HX et du coup on sait que le gradient
qui rapporte à ce moment-là le lecteur 0
sur ce point sera égal à - HX ok
maintenant est-ce que c'est sa stratégie
optimale bien si la région optimale
était cette ellipsoïde qui est un
ensemble convexe alors le point le plus
proche qui pourra obtenir ça serait
nécessairement la projection orthogonale
sur cet ensemble convexe en particulier
sur ce dessin ça correspondrait à dire
que à cet endroit là il doit y avoir un
angle droit maintenant supposons que
Tata zéro est extrêmement proche de
cette ellipsoïde de sorte que cet
endroit optimal en fait il est aussi
très proche de la médiane géométrique
qui sera rapporté lorsqu'il est honnête
dans sa révélation des préférences
pourquoi pourquoi c'est intéressant de
faire ça parce que en fait c'est assez
facile de calculer à cet endroit là
l'orthogonale la direction normale à
l'ellipsoïde puisque l'ellipsoïde étant
une ligne de niveau de la fonction qui
au vecteur x associe la norme de HX au
carré pour connaître la direction du
gradient à cet endroit elle suffit de
calculer le gradient de la norme de HX
au carré et ça il se trouve que c'est le
gradient d'une forme quadratique dont on
connaît bien la dérivée qui va être égal
à deux fois hHX et du coup on se rend
compte que la direction entre les médias
géométrique et tu es à 0 c'est pas tout
à fait la même que la direction entre
États zéro et là sa projection
orthogonale parce que d'un côté on a HX
et de l'autre côté on a hHX et c'est
vraiment cette différence de direction
qui fait que tetha zéro ici a intérêt à
mentir et peut gagner beaucoup en
particulier plus HX et différent de HX
et même de façon plus précise moins ils
sont colinéaires et bien plus il y aura
à gagner pour l'utilisateur zéro en
montant sur sa préférence et donc dans
le PLK on se rend compte que les
intérêts à mentir sont particulièrement
grands quand la matrice H a tendance à
Tordre à tourner comme ça elle est
certain vecteurs et en fait à quel point
elle tourne ses vecteurs c'est ce qu'on
a défini formellement comme étant
skinness de cette matrice c'est une
terminologie c'est un néologisme c'est
un terminologie nouvelle dans
l'université à toi en tout cas pourtant
qu'on sache donc je sais pas trop
comment traduire ce que en français mais
voilà à quel point ça tord l'espace tout
ça est en fait très haut il y a une
histoire d'angle entre les vecteurs en
fait c'est un produit scalaire divisé
par les normes des différents vecteurs
donc c'est vraiment une histoire d'angle
et donc c'est vraiment cette screeneuse
qui quantifie à quel point il y a un
risque qui est beaucoup d'intérêt à
mentir pour certains utilisateurs dans
article en particulier on relit ça à
ratio entre les valeurs absolues
extrêmes de la matrice sienne bon
malheureusement on n'a pas de formule
exact et je suis pas sûr qu'il y a une
formule exacte en tout cas à partir des
valeurs propres pour obtenir cette
mesure de à quel point ça tort l'espace
mais nos inégalités montrent en tout cas
clairement que plus il y a des
différences entre les valeurs propres
c'est à dire plus certaines dimensions
sont beaucoup plus polarisés que
d'autres puis il y a d'intérêt à mentir
sur référence et ça ça correspond
vraiment aux animations que j'ai fait à
la fin de la vidéo précédente
les grandes idées de la preuve que nous
a guidés ça va marcher mais il faut
quand même faire le travail de vérifier
que ça va marcher et en fait il y a
plusieurs difficultés qui qui viennent
et l'une des difficultés par exemple
c'est de passer du cas fini à ce cas à
sympathique ou les approximations sont
vraies en particulier dire que la région
de l'espace c'était lipsoïde qui est une
approximation et suffisamment bonne
approximation du vrai espace
atteignable tibles et vraiment l'astuce
c'est vraiment d'essayer d'identifier
tous les objets vraiment clés à la
preuve et de montrer que les valeurs que
ces objets prennent quand il y a un très
grand nombre de contributeurs vont être
extrêmement proches d’œil du cas
insectique où on a vraiment une
distribution continue des différents
contributeurs qui est le cas qui
correspond vraiment à l'ellipsoïde
exacte donc j'ai parlé précédemment et
typiquement pour y arriver on va
utiliser beaucoup d'inégalités de
holding enfin c'est ce qu'on appelle les
inégalités de concentration parfois qui
sont un peu des valeurs fortes et
vraiment utiles en pratique de du
théorème central limite notamment pour
des cas d'épication on cherche à prouver
que tout se passera bien contrôlez
vraiment les garanties donc c'est
vraiment des techniques assez classiques
pour avoir des résultats avec grande
probabilités à partir d'hypothèses
probabilités sur un très grand nombre de
cas sachant que un certain moment dans
la preuve en fait ces inégalités ne
suffisait pas parce que il fallait voir
des des inégalités uniformes sur un
ensemble typiquement de gradients autour
du point d'équilibre donc cesignated
marche en gros assez bien quand on
cherche à contrôler un nombre fini de
variables réelles mais quand c'est un
nombre continue de c'est plus compliqué
et dans ces cas là on a dû faire preuve
d'un peu plus d'ingéniosité pour essayer
de contrôler le temps que possible
toutes les variations par rapport au cas
infinies une autre difficulté c'est que
dans le cas finit en fait il y a
beaucoup de points de critique de points
où les dérivés ne sont plus définies
puisque le gradient d'un d'une norme EN
le point donné ça fait un vecteur enfin
ça fait une sous différentielle pour
être technique mais du coup aussi les
dérives et secondes ne sont plus défin
donc il faut essayer d'écarter ces
points et du coup en fait l'astuce qu'on
a trouvé pour écarter ses points c'est
de montrer en fait qui sont assez loin
que en fait ce qui se passe surtout en
grande dimension en fait nos terrains
nous sont valables quand dimension
supérieur à 5 en dimension supérieure à
5 en fait les points assez loin les uns
des autres généralement et ça ça nous
permet vraiment de contrôler tout ce qui
se passe et d'ajouter plus de continuité
sous nos approximations finies donc en
fait le problème des incitatifs
asymptotiques de la mania géométrique
sont encore ouverts en dimension de 3 et
4 en tout cas le fait de d'avoir une
borne supérieure parce que nos exemples
montrent déjà qu'en dimension 2 par
contre on peut avoir des bornes des
stratifs aussi grandes que l'on veut la
preuve qui montre l'absence de stratégie
pro-nest de Alpha stretchness fonctionne
déjà en dimension 2 enfin une troisième
difficulté c'était de montrer que la
région des points atteignables étaient
un ensemble convexe qui est vraiment un
argument critique pour pouvoir appliquer
l'argument de la projection
orthogonale
et aussi l'histoire d'angle et donc
c'était vraiment critique d'avoir ce
résultat et pour l'avoir en fait il
fallait vraiment creuser et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça dépend en fait
la dérivée troisième
fois que je manipule des dérivés 3e en
grande dimension c'était assez
perturbant et marrant d'étudier ses
objets qui sont du coup des tenseurs qui
dépendent de trois variables et en gros
en très gros ce qui se passe c'est que
cette dérivée troisième en fait elle est
de moins en moins gênante plus il y a de
contributeurs et dans le moment en fait
on peut dire que à partir d'un certain
contributeurs voilà ça ça a un effet
suffisamment négligeable que on peut
conclure que l'ensemble est convexe
dernière chose avant de conclure je vais
parler du théorème qui généralise un peu
nos résultats au cas où les préférences
sont non isotropiques et où on peut
utiliser des médias géométriques dans ce
qu'on appelle déformé Scudo métrique
médiane bon pour commencer qu'est-ce que
sont des préférences non les autres pics
en fait dans toutes nos preuves on
suppose que la que les contributeurs ont
un point préféré et également ont une
préférence entre les positions des
médianes géométriques lorsque sont pas
leurs lieux préférés en particulier ce
qu'on suppose c'est que il préfère que
Diane géométrique soit aussi proche que
possible de leur points préférés en
distance euclidienne et donc ça ça
en gros du sens si on considère le
problème dans l'espace client physique
mais dès qu'on considère que l'espace en
fait RD correspond à d'autres choses par
exemple ça peut correspondre à
répartition des budgets entre différents
départements où ça peut correspondre aux
paramètres d'un réseau neurones et bien
dans ces deux cas il peut avoir
certaines direction de l'espace qui sont
plus importantes pour utilisateurs que
c'est très important pour un électeur
que tel entreprise exactement telle
budget et puis peut-être que pour tel
autre c'est pas grave si ça varie un peu
plus de la même façon c'est peut-être
très important que l'algorithme
recommande vraiment ce genre de contenu
et nous recommande pas sueur de contenu
et puis pour d'autres contenus et on
peut être un peu moins un peu plus lâche
et bien ça ça arrive vraiment enfin
c'est vraiment des hypothèses
extrêmement importantes en pratique très
réaliste et bien on peut intégrer sous
lors de phénomènes dans notre modèle en
disant que ce que les utilisateurs
cherchent à minimiser n'est pas la
distance entre la médiane géométriques
et leurs points préférés mais une autre
norme qu'on va définir comme étant la
norme de du matrice S qui va donner de
plus important à certaines dimensions
plutôt qu'à d'autres donc une matrice
semi-définie positive avec des valeurs
propres qui sont pas forcément toutes
égales entre elles donc on suppose que
c'était un cherche à minimiser la norme
de s fois la médiane géométrique moins
leurs points préférés
bien dans ce cas nos preuves se
généralisent assez naturellement en fait
il y a une jolie astuce pour pouvoir les
généraliser assez vite c'est ça consiste
à se dire que plutôt que d’étudier le
problème dans un espace dans l'espace
quotidien on va déformer d'abord
l'espace de sorte que dans cet espace
défaut mais la préférence de
l'utilisateur et isotropique et à ce
moment-là on va réappliquer les mêmes
arguments et en particulier l'avantage
de faire ça c'est que la meilleure
stratégie pour l'utilisateur stratégique
ça reste la projection orthogonale mais
cette fois dans l'espace bien sûr
déformé pour que ces préférences soient
isotropiques enfin une dernière chose
qu'on montre c'est que on peut avoir des
propriétés similaires si on considère
non pas la médiane géométrique mais la
médiane géométrique déformée ce que une
multiométrique médiane qui consiste
simplement à calculer la médiane
géométrique mais dans un espace déformé
et puis de se revenir dans l'espace
normal de le retraduire dans l'espace
Norman ça de façon équivalente ça
revient à prendre un point qui minimise
la Somme des distances mais selon une
norme non euclidienne selon une norme
que je vais appeler pseudo-éclidienne
c'est à dire qui est de la forme norme
de une matrice de déformation fois que
j'ai appelé ici Sigma fois le vecteur
dont on cherche à calculer la norme il a
encore en gros des arguments
fonctionnant encore en fait il suffit de
se rendre compte que on obtiendra
l'ensemble des points atteignables sera
encore un ellipsoïde mais qui maintenant
dépend également de cette matrice
déformée petite remarque par rapport à
ça c'est qu'en fait le contrôle de la
matrice sienne que l'on obtient ainsi
lorsqu'on déforme la médiane géométrique
ça va pas se calculer facilement en
fonction de cette déformation
malheureusement notamment la médiane
géométrique va potentiellement se
déplacer puisque la médiane géométrique
n'est pas invariante par ce genre de
transformation non euclidienne non
métrique de l'espace comme la mutation
par une matrice h à la semi-défini
positive et du coup
en fait on n'arrive pas à avoir un
contrôle vraiment comme on aimerait de
ce genre de truc et en particulier on
n'est pas capable de montrer que pour
toute distribution des préférences il
existe une matrice de déformation pour
laquelle la médiane géométrique avec
cette matrice de déformation et à
synthétique lit stratégieproof voilà
c'est un problème ouvert si cela vous
intéresse vous pouvez regarder ce
problème
je préfère dire que c'est pas facile
voilà ça conclut cette vidéo hardcore
donc comme vous avez peut-être pu le
sentir c'était pas la vidéo la plus
préparée comme pas mal de mes vidéos
hardcore mais j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'était cool de refaire des maths et
petit teaser en fait comme en fait on a
travaillé sur beaucoup d'articles de
recherche motivés par ces idées
notamment de sécuriser autant que
possible les algorithmes de tournesol on
a fait pas mal de maths par rapport à ça
et au fur et à mesure que les articles
vont être acceptés en espérant qu'il qui
le soit assez rapidement dans les venus
Academy et bien je serai amené à
reparler encore des mathématiques de la
sécurisation non seulement des
instruments certifiés mais plus
généralement des algorithmes qui
maîtrisent le flux d'information à
travers le monde